in this episode of the roadside mba
we're on our way to atlanta california
to visit scott turbin mixer
a small american manufacturer that makes
the biggest blenders you've ever seen
you're ready i'm ready
where we test our talents with power
tools tell my children i love them play
with fire
i got it and find out how one tough
little company beats back the
competition with process innovation a
highly skilled workforce and
one-of-a-kind custom-made products
we're cruising down highway 99
headed for southern california the land
of sand and sunshine and the place we're
going it's got plenty of both
just not in the way you might think if
there's the end of the world we may be
very close to it
the small city of atalanta is about two
hours drive east from the beaches of los
angeles right on the edge of the mojave
desert it seems like it's on the very
edge of civilization all you see is
desert and a little bit of scrub and
there's not much else out there welcome
to the high desert beach community thank
you scott shaffer yeah
but businessman bill scott says it's a
perfect place for a small american
manufacturer to fly below the radar and
compete in a tough global market how
would you describe bill scott
bill scott is a character welcome we're
at about 3 200 feet elevation
southern california and we have more
sand than the beach does phil's company
scott turbin mixer has been here for 30
years making one-of-a-kind custom
stainless steel industrial mixing
machines pretty slick huh
his customers use these massive blenders
to mix everything from salad mix to
pharmaceuticals and soft drinks we would
sell this little machine to somebody
like pepsi and coke for mixing aspartame
sodium of potassium benzoate caffeine
pectin you know minor ingredients that
go into soda
the central product and crowning glory
of scot mixer is this an industrial
mixing head designed by bill scott
himself unlike previous mixing heads it
combines ingredients from the top and
bottom of the tank at the same time
effectively doubling the production
capacity the upper cone or pump pulls
down the lower cone or pump sucks up and
the discharge is actually
across those teeth
and that gives the shear so we're
circulating and we're shearing bill
patented his invention in 1980 which
gave him a head start on the competition
but his patent ran out more than 15
years ago one thing that i thought was
fascinating about these guys is
he had intellectual property rights and
for a while that
allowed him to kind of milk the patent
if you will but the patent ran out and
now
there's no more barrier to entry
somebody can come make the exact same
mixing machine i think the patent gave
the company a big head start a 17-year
head start but the patent itself and
that head start isn't enough now that
anyone can make the same mixer head bill
knew he had to do more to keep customers
so he decided to become a one-stop shop
for the whole mixing process one thing
you see out there is how vertically
integrated this firm is they are not
focusing on making mixer heads and
buying parts from other companies to put
the whole system together they're
essentially making the entire mixing
system from scratch themselves but to
make a complicated high-quality
customized product you need employees
who have stuck around long enough to
learn the tricks of the trade
making these one-off machines means that
processes can't be standardized you're
almost never doing the same thing on
consecutive days and it means that the
company needs a relatively high skilled
workforce jay is making a plastic
bushing jay's a really good manual
machinist it takes a high skill level to
make manual parts very high now we don't
want to let jay know that that we really
depend on him
he probably knows already
bill keeps his employees around by
offering job security in a remote area
with high unemployment whereas workers
can provide for their families and
afford to buy homes he wants to make
sure that he always has an experienced
workforce so he hasn't laid off a single
employee even during the great recession
of 2008 and 2009. jose's been with me
for over 20 years
25 25 years excuse me jose
you can't do it without them and
retraining employees is extremely
expensive and very disruptive
so as an employer it's incredibly
important to me if they're good
employees to keep them as long as i can
give me eight hours of good work
and i in turn will make sure that
there's red on the table and you can
plan your life he has a large share of
the workforce that has been here 15 20
25 years
and
that's really important because
to create value for the customer he
needs to combine both the technology
with the experience of the workers and
these loyal highly skilled employees
make a very high-end mixer one that a
competitor with a less experienced staff
can't match even after the patent has
expired i focus on high performance
there's a segment of the population that
will buy a ferrari or a lamborghini or a
porsche
that's the customer that i focus on bill
says he refuses to cut corners using
stainless steel just for looks rather
than cheaper plain steel not only do you
want it highly functional and to last or
perform or do whatever you want it to do
but you want it to look good could you
replace a lot of stainless steel with
absolutely i could yeah steel absolutely
i can make almost all my machines steel
the problem is what do they look like in
six months or a year well what about
even plastics or it's not me
it's not me so one by one each machine
is polished to a mirror finish and every
single weld is carefully buffed smooth
here
and you can see what they look like
before he started to grind and polish
them look at this weld thing is perfect
i take a lot of pride in the way that
our equipment works it's assumed that
it's going to kick butt but if it looks
great
compared to all the other equipments in
that factory it just sparkles
and you saw these big machines they're
beautiful
as machines go they're drop dead
gorgeous
so how hard is it really what goes into
making a ferrari of mixers
i get a chance to find out myself
we started in the polishing room
this is like i feel like the flight
attendant
giving the little lesson on the airplane
you ready i'm ready
that's cool
how'd i do
i had the mask on upside down so one of
us knows what he's doing
do i need to redo it
don't tell anyone the other job i tried
was welding that's really hard work just
get as comfortable as possible and make
a practice pass
the guy who showed me how to do it has
been doing it for two years and he said
he's still not nearly as good as some of
the people who've been doing it a lot
longer
tell my children i love them
i had visions of my finger being zapped
and going up in smoke but i was probably
more careful than i needed to be to make
sure that wasn't an issue what'd i do
wrong you have to hold it down
there you go
you know you're touching it
turns out i am not a natural
ah got it and finally i'm welding
sort of i can tell you that after doing
it for 10 minutes i am terrible at it i
well did this however but you know even
that is not quite true because the guy
who showed me how to do it did most of
the work
you couldn't look at the welding
directly because that's dangerous if
you're not wearing the helmet i didn't
see the welding as much as i saw the
output and i think that
he needs a little bit more training on
that
did we shoot enough
i'm not very good at this
oh well
so much for my dream of a second career
as a welder
working on the shop floor has given me a
newfound respect for the craftsmanship
that goes into making these mixers but
creating a quality product is only part
of the challenge of building a
successful business before we got to the
factory floor we saw a little tour of
their office area and it was interesting
to me how the office area was organized
as well they had some sales people and
some people who were quoting jobs and
across that area they had the engineers
who are working on the design that's
really important in a company to make
sure that you don't
produce things you can't sell or sell
things that you can't engineer and i
really like how they were able to keep
that communication together this is a
business where it's really important
for somebody to be talking to the
customer and really understanding what's
going on inside the customer's processes
and that's a role that bill himself has
played for many years you can't get away
from the customer a lot of people you
know close the door
they take two months vacations they do
all these things and it's a wonder i'd
love to be able to do that in my opinion
though you can easily lose track of what
the essence of the company is about with
so much competition out there
understanding customers and their needs
is the key to making each and every deal
and then there's confidence as the
driving force behind this company bill
has plenty of it dan one of my guys was
asked me today he says well what happens
if this went away tomorrow
and i said dan there's so many
opportunities out there right now it did
take me a couple months and i could
figure something
they're everywhere opportunities one of
the
things we like to ask at the end is what
keeps you up at night
nothing i'm sleeping
and that's it
one man in a mixer
and three economists
an rv the open road and a lot of time
together there's no npr to be had out
here yeah
i couldn't find anything
next stop a desert dude ranch in
northwestern arizona
where people just like us
leave the cushy city life behind
to see if we have what it takes to be a
cowboy